all right everybody uh it's quarter past
and at this point i would normally say
all right who needs more time and so on
however um you might be you might have
been noticing or maybe you were
too busy uh in your own book i've been
sort of trying to help you along just a
little bit
um but i've tried to give you a head
start to make sure i wasn't spoiling
anything
um too too massive i'm just going to
walk you through now and i want to make
sure we get to
the end of this because you can quite
easily get caught up in all of the
algebra going to mrs lee's and i point
from earlier today
a lot of kind of what you need to be um
to solve this question
is very fluent at what you've learned in
advance with um
your log laws with you know taking care
of your algebra
we have actually by this point um done
most of the stuff that is quote unquote
extension two and then the rest of your
brain needs to make sure it knows what
it's doing
uh and doesn't make any serially
arithmetic errors or things like that
okay
so let's chat a course through this
where i left you was
we determined what the initial
horizontal velocity was
and we called it 60 cos theta because we
didn't know what theta was
because that's what the question is find
out what the angular projection
is equal to so when you go ahead and you
substitute that into
this equation that we got from our first
integration and my second integration
is on its way shortly this is what you
get i've got this weird negative
index here so i've opted to turn that
into a fraction down below
now from there i've just substituted in
that constant here it is
and at this point i'm now going to begin
working you can see my lines here that
will ensue
where i'm trying to head towards is
something that i can integrate with
respect to time
that'll get me to a displacement
equation because of course x dot
is just dx on dt so i can integrate that
especially since i do have this as a
function of time
um theta remember is a constant k and m
are constants
uh so therefore that's my destination
that's where i want to get to i want an
x dot equation that's nice and neat
which i'm almost there in my working
and then i'm going to integrate find
that next constant
so from here um you can see uh i was
just doing a bit of tidying up i've got
a you know negative signs everywhere so
i multiplied through by negative one
at this point here i decided to take a
little bit of inspiration from um
i think it was xiao who mentioned it's
like hey we can keep on going with a
fraction
i'm not going to do this forever you'll
see it's going to get rapidly messy
but 9.8 on 44 squared is what you get
from
k divided by m remembering that k if you
go back up here you can see me doing
this working over here
k has m in it right so when you do k
divided by m it just
drops off and you just get all of this
stuff so i don't know why i put these
minus signs here we don't need them
so that's the 9.8 on 44 squared that has
appeared in my working
and then from this point here i've
noticed that on the left hand side i
don't have x dot
i have the reciprocal of x dot so you
can see i've combined it into this
slightly awful fraction here because
once i have a single fraction
i can turn it upside down get the
reciprocal which is what i've just done
on this line here now i hope you can
tell me
go ahead and post it in the chat looking
at this i know it looks like a terrible
mess because of the numbers and because
of the premium rules but can you tell me
what family of functions this will
belong to when i go ahead
and integrate because remember this x
dot this is actually
as mentioned before this is dx on dt so
think back yes well done excellent
sesame was in
first but doesn't matter if you're in
first i hope you're all ticking over and
you're thinking
this is going to be a log function
because it looks very much like f dash
on f we're pretty close right if this is
my
f of t then f dash will be
9.8 times 60 cos theta i've already got
the 60 cos theta there it's just
this is not quite right so i'm just
going to have to multiply through by or
divide through
by an appropriate constant so i'm going
to do that just on the next line
dx on dt is equal to
what do i need to divide through by and
the answer is pull that 44 squared out
and then divide by 9.8 so that you will
get the 9.8
on your numerator because that's going
to be part of your x
sorry your f dash so there's that
let me be exceptionally lazy as i
already have been today that's going to
be my denominator because i haven't
fiddled with it
and there's a nice straight line there
okay
so at this point ready to go let's go
ahead and integrate
this 44 squared on 9.8 that was the
constant coefficient
that i pulled out and then when you have
a look at this it's already in the
precise
form i want f dash on f so therefore i'm
quite happy to go straight to
log of everything that was on that
denominator there so maybe i should put
this as a big square bracket
because i've got parentheses inside so
i'm going to duplicate that
as has been discussed in previous
mechanics questions i don't really need
to concern myself
with um absolute value signs around my
log
and just think for a second about why um
when you have a look at this
your time is going to be um positive and
when you think about your angles here
right
60 cos theta um what domain is relevant
well this is an angle of projection and
presumably the golfer is going to hit
the ball
forward so therefore your angle of
projection is going to
be between nor and 90. it's going to be
an acute angle between 0 and 90 or not
in pi on 2 i suppose i should say since
we're doing calculus
um cos theta is positive right we're in
the first quadrant so therefore
um you've got positive positive positive
positive
very very positive so that's why you can
see i'm like
don't worry about the absolute value
signs that's unnecessary
of course my integral is not finished
yet i do have another constant flying
around it's going to be constant 2.
all right now just like before i used
the initial conditions but with velocity
um here i've got the initial conditions
for displacement but they're even easier
to use
the initial condition is that when time
is zero you start at the origin so you
get
x equals zero so you can see all these
delightful terms here
get get that one there and this one here
they're all going to collapse to zero
so what do you get left with i hope you
can see
that you're going to get constant 2 is
just going to be
um the negative of this right because
it'll they'll both end up on the right
hand side together
and you just need to subtract right so
it'll be 44 squared or 9.8
multiplied by log of 44 squared
right so when you go ahead and evaluate
that um
i got on my calculator and i'm just i'm
only going to write down two decimal
places but i actually have many more
in my calculator this is what i got
dot dot dot i suppose so could you give
me a a thumbs up or a
hooray or whatever in the chat if that's
where you landed
or if you've got something different
please wave and be
uh you know register your alarm with me
but that was what i got when i
evaluated i just i'll just write it for
clarity here
44 squared on 9.8
log of 44 squared that's what i got
there
i'm not getting much in the chat so i'm
assuming that means perhaps you didn't
get there or maybe some of your working
um
wasn't the same as what i got up above
so as i get to the end of this and
finish it off
and you're welcome to go back to the
recording if i'm going a little bit fast
for you i apologize i'm just mindful of
the time
you can tell me if i made an error
somewhere in here okay
so i'm just going to take this as my
value for the constant
so what i'm going to do is i can say x
equals and then i have everything here
i guess i don't really need this
highlighting and i'm going to take away
that constant which i just evaluated
which was minus
1495.14
okay so this is what i know and at this
point i'm like wow
i finally arrived at this displacement
question uh equation
in terms of time what was i trying to do
again okay if you go back
all the way to our question it says
calculate the angle of projection find
theta that's what i need to know
if theta is my real unknown if you have
a look at this equation we've arrived at
here's theta let me just highlight it
for you
there it is right there in order to
evaluate theta
i'm going to need to get rid of every
other pronumeral right i'm going gonna
need to get rid of or substitute
something appropriate for x
and substitute something else
appropriate for time now i've already
used my initial condition
time zero so that's done i'm not gonna
get any more information from that
can someone go ahead and post in the
chat even if you haven't gotten the
answer to this yet
what information can i use to work out
what my theta is going to be and that's
going to be our final
answer can someone tell me what is the
last bit of data we haven't made
use of yet
i've got some people who are uh have an
idea but not
quite brave enough to put it in the
public chat okay fantastic yay i've got
lots of people thank you
liam sham gru well done we don't just
have the initial condition
we actually also have as it were the
final condition
i'm not worrying about what happens
after it bounces um i know the flight
time
which is 4.53 seconds and i know
where i land because we were told the
golfer hits the ball
and it lands 155 meters away so i can
use
that piece of information
now because our numbers look horrendous
this is going to get messy fast i did
say you're going to need your calculator
here but i want to emphasize to you
right
actually the important part of your
thinking here is not about the
arithmetic
um so it's the concept that's the thing
we want to emphasize but of course
you're getting the right answer or not
does depend on your arithmetic um being
valid
so if for example you were to write an
answer like 155 there's my x
equals 44 squared or 9.8
log of here we go 9.8
uh times 60 cos theta times
there's the 4.53 from the time plus
44 squared minus this
constant 2. um you know you've done most
of the work here right can you see from
this point you just need to do some
careful manipulation
and make theta the subject it is tucked
all the way inside
um that terrible log term but you can
hopefully chart a path through here
right
uh you're gonna need to add um together
these constants to get them all together
on the left-hand side
divide through by this one and then
you'll have a log equation
right so what i'm going to do is try and
um
carry this along for you and as i go i i
started to evaluate numbers because
um like 9.8 times 60 times 4.53
i'm not gaining anything by writing them
out separately anymore so i'm actually
going to go ahead
and evaluate them all right here's what
i got so far
um i start with this 44 squared on 9.8
which i
evaluated as about 198
that's what i got there uh it's
multiplied by that log
and then inside the brackets here and
maybe i'll just try and highlight this
so you can see the
what i'm actually evaluating um i did
9.8 times 60 times 4.53 and i got
something
around the 2 600 mark so this was the
number
that i got and you can go ahead and
check that in your calculator
that's still multiplied by cos theta
because i don't know what theta is
i worked out what 44 squared was as well
it's 1936
and then while i was at it i added this
constant actually i'll highlight it
i'll try and highlight this so you can
keep track of where i got things from
i added this 1490
to 155 and what i got was
uh uh 1650
and then the one four of course is
hanging around so that's where i got
that from you can see where i've added
i'm just going to divide through now so
you get left with this log on the left
hand side
don't need to highlight that and
1 600 ish divided by 200 ish
gives you something in the 8 ballpark so
i got 8.353 and obviously
a whole lot more decimals from there now
at this point a bit cheeky i've been
writing it in natural log
this whole time because i'm lazy but
that's really shorthand for log
base e so if i'm going to get that theta
that's tucked all the way in there i'm
going to need to convert this
logarithmic equation
into an exponential equation so that's
exactly what i did on the next line
i took this part in here
and i said well that's going to be equal
to what's the base
it's e raised to this which is the power
so
i should say the the index so it's e to
the power of 8.353
whatever that happens to be and we're
pretty close now right you can just see
there's a little bit of rearrangement to
go
so i'm going to subtract that 1936 from
both sides which leaves me with
this e to the 8.353
take away 1936. i need to divide through
to get cos theta so that's gonna give me
this
unchanged but i'm going to divide
through by that
weirder looking coefficient out there 2
600 something
i apologize i know that i can write much
faster than you then i can copy and
paste but you didn't get a head start
and at this point here i reached my
calculator
again and i wondered what you got i got
zero point
and then i wonder if you want to post in
the chat what you've evaluated there you
can see we're all at this point here
i'll wait for the first person to get
there because that will give me an
indication that i haven't been writing
way too fast maybe i have
anyone get there with their calculator
okay so yes i've got um 8.660 and then
what trails after this is just basically
going to depend
on at what point you simplified or
approximated i should say
and whether you've got all of the exact
values in your calculator and using all
of those or in desmos or whatever is
appropriate
now i hope you look at that number and
it looks weirdly familiar eight
0.866 you're like hold on a second i've
seen this before
um it's almost like the question was
designed to do this that's a whole lot
like root three on two because this
question has been designed
to land you of course we've done
approximation all the way through
i got very very close to 30. i got
29.995 dot
and that was probably just owing the
approximations that i did honestly
um so that gives me an angle of
projection of about
30 degrees you're like i can't believe i
went all that way and i got
an angle that was almost exact value so
the answer that we were looking for
there's the angle of projection
so look we're right on the dot um i know
that was a challenging question to open
up with but i hope you could see through
the algebra
um the algebraic and arithmetic soup
that we had to get through
the key things i wanted to highlight and
i'll go back to that just in a second if
you wanted to copy that down
the key things i wanted to highlight
were number one under a quadratic drag
moment
model rather you don't end up with a
simple exponential equation we got with
linear drag
and then secondly you know they can ask
a question from whichever angle they
want
pardon the pun um you know here's the
drag coefficient here's the angle
projection find out everything else or
as in this case
um here's a bunch of pieces of
information about where the golf ball
landed and how fast i hit it
now you tell me the drag coefficient and
what angle i struck it
at so as promised let me come back down
to here
and i'll leave that on screen and we've
hit half past so thank you for working
hard with me i know that was a bit of a
slog
but i really appreciate your effort and
your thought especially at this time in
the morning